comment passer d'une idée
un projet concret d'un rêve à une
réalité
quand j'ai créé dehors et devin en
partant de zéro
bonjour à tous mon nom c'est Michel
Lanou je suis colombien j'ai 29 ans je
suis né à Mani salé une petite ville
magnifique au milieu des montagnes et
des fonds de café j'ai vécu plus de 20
ans entre l'Uruguay et l'Argentine où
j'ai découvert mon premier amour pour le
vin et la gastronomie et la grosse
gastronomie
j'ai vécu plus de six mois on Inde où
j'ai découvert le monde de l'innovation
et des nouvelles technologies notamment
l'innovation du Gad et le design smoking
alors l'innovation du gaz 5 concepts
très simples c'est pouvoir créer des
produits et des services
dans un contexte de ressources limitées
sont très utilisateur qui permet à tout
à chacun de pouvoir partir d'une idée
d'une problématique bien précise et
pouvoir créer des produits ou des
services innovants à travers des boucles
itératives
dans l'idée de pouvoir tester le plus
rapidement possible des idées dans un
marché
puis ça fait 7 ans que je suis venu à
Paris m'installer
je suis venu finaliser mon Master 2
innovation management de nouvelles
technologies à la Sorbonne où j'ai pu
rencontrer ce qui allait devenir mon
futur associé
tout de suite après mon master
je décide de suivre un rêve le rêve
d'entreprendre de faire le pas
d'entrepreneuriat de créer ma propre
société
de choisir mes missions être mon propre
patron
sortir des sentiers battus
et finalement
faire ce que je voulais faire
mais je vous avoue au début je n'étais
pas très sur un je faisais pas trop le
malin je savais pas comment m'y prendre
et j'avais que très peu d'expérience
je décide tout de même d'appliquer une
méthodologie entre
l'innovation juges et l'usine
le but étant de pouvoir tester le plus
rapidement possible des idées et voir si
ça fonctionne dans un marché précis
ma première idée était de pouvoir
outsour C du coup sous-traiter des
missions que j'aurais pu trouver en
France à l'international on Inde où
j'avais énormément de contacts près à me
suivre
je commence à créer des profils
développeurs designers sur toutes les
plateformes de freelance à l'époque
freelance.com
et je vois si ça fonctionne j'attends je
laisse de temps passer
et finalement je me rends compte que
c'était pas une bonne idée ça ça ne
marchait pas
l'émission à l'international était très
concurrentielle notamment par les prix à
la baisse l'émission que je trouvais en
France c'était pas vraiment ce que je
voulais faire c'était pas c'était pas ce
qui me plaisait
je décide de changer de stratégie de
pivoter je décide de mes spécialiser
dans un blockchain et un client
artificiel
des domaines qui me passionnent et qu'à
l'époque on entendait de plus en plus
parler dans le monde professionnel
j'attends je vois je vois si ça
fonctionne
et bingo une entreprise me contacte très
peu de temps après à la recherche d'un
freelance capable de le régulier sur les
stratégies en innovation dans la
blockchain il y a toujours artificielle
il souhaitait quelqu'un capable de leur
vulgariser la technologie leur expliquer
les teneurs et aboutissants de celle-ci
les opportunités
mais aussi les risques la capacité de
pouvoir créer des cas d'usage entreprise
et ça super bien match
cette expérience cette mission on a
appelé d'autres et depuis à petit le fil
en aiguille j'ai commencé à faire mon
petit portefeuille de clients
4 ans après je me rends compte que tous
les challenges à l'époque sont devenus
petit à petit ma zone de confort
le covid arrive je décide de me lancer
dans une nouvelle expérience faire de
nouveau à le pas de l'entrepreneuriat
cette fois-ci elle est la recherche d'un
rêve
pouvoir revenir à mes premières amours
le vin et la gastronomie
mon objectif pouvoir moderniser
l'expérience d'achat des consommateurs
grâce aux nouvelles technologies mais
comment m'y prendre dans un monde aussi
concurrentiel
aussi traditionnelle comme le vin
je décide de nouveau d'appliquer cette
méthodologie entre un mi-chemin entre le
design thinking et l'innovation du gaz
dans le but de pouvoir tester le plus
rapidement possible des idées et voir si
ça fonctionne
je commence à m'intéresser au parcours
de consommation des utilisateurs des
amateurs de vin je fais appel à mon
réseau
je fais des interviews je me rends
compte très rapidement que le conseil
c'est un facteur clé dans leur
expérience d'achat
que ce soit c'est son caviste ou dans un
restaurant mistonomique
étoilé gastronomique le rôle du
sommelier est très important il est là
pour transmettre la philosophie du
vignoble
la philosophie du vigneron
il est là pour donner les conseils en
accord mais et vins des conseils en
dégustation
et finalement ce conseil est totalement
absent des plateformes de conseils des
plateformes de vente de vin en ligne je
décide donc de créer la première
plateforme de conseil vente et livraison
devant l'exception à domicile qui met au
centre des cinémas le conseil
le concept de bien défini
Manu manquait plus qu'une équipe une
équipe capable de la développer de A à Z
un peu comme l'innovation
j'avais cette chance que à ce moment
Quentin mon pote de l'université
souhaitait faire le pas de
l'entrepreneuriat comme moi avec une
connaissance dans le vin et dans le
marketing et la communication il décide
de définir tous les stratégies moi je
prends la casquette technique
n'étant pas développeurs de base je
décide de me autoformer dans les dans le
nos codes et de développer la première
plateforme
mais il ne manquait une personne il nous
manque une personne de l'équipe capable
de bien comprendre
le secteur une personne avec de
l'expérience dans le vin
finalement il nous manquait un Zizou de
la sommellerie pour faire binôme avec
Messi
on avait dans notre réseau
le président de l'association des
sommeliers de Paris Maître Sommelier
avec plus de 40 années d'expérience on a
contacté il a tout de suite accroché sur
le projet il nous a rejoint en même
temps c'était plus facile parce que
c'est le père de Quentin mon pote
entre les trois on a créé une super
équipe plein de synergies on a développé
la plateforme en quelques semaines on
l'a fait tester à des premières
utilisateurs et on a eu des super bons
retours super bon retour notamment sur
la livraison on est parti au début sur
une livraison moins de 3 heures
on entendait parler des applications
livraison moins de 15 minutes pour ses
courses et on s'est dit c'est le crayon
à prendre on s'est vraiment une
opportunité comme ça on pourra se
différencier de la concurrence
finalement on entend donc parler les
amateurs de vin
on se rend compte que c'était pas
finalement quelque chose où ils avaient
une vraie attente eux ils ont l'habitude
d'acheter en quantité 6 12 24 bouteilles
ils ont l'habitude d'avoir la petite est
stock avoir finalement la bouteille déjà
acheter il y a longtemps et finalement
le 2-3 heures c'était pas très
intéressant on modifie la stratégie donc
et on le fait en deux trois jours et ça
a complètement matché leurs besoins
je suis dans l'aiguille de bouche à
bouche à oreille
le référencement naturel commence à
marcher et on commence à voir nos
premiers clients nos premières ventes et
le business commence à tourner
et là se pose la question de comment
aller à l'échelle comment se développe
plus rapidement comment prendre plus de
part de marché et donc naturellement la
question du financement
voilà cette chance que on était en train
de on était inscrit dans un concours de
start-up on est l'horaire French tech on
arrive à voir notre première source de
financement pour investir encore plus
dans la tech recruter notre première
salariés avoir nos propres locaux
et après on décide d'aller toquer dans
les portes des banques on arrive à voir
notre première crédit qui nous permet
finalement de maintenir développer le
business jusqu'aujourd'hui
on est plus de 10 à travailler pour le
même objectif
on commence à se développer à
l'international et à créer de nouveaux
services notamment à la restauration
il y avait qu'un peu de recul de mes
deux expériences
avec une rétrospective de mon parcours
aujourd'hui me pose la question de
qu'est-ce que pour moi visualiser ma
réussite pour moi visualiser sa réussite
passe avant tout par pouvoir se projeter
dans la concrétisation de ses rêves par
trois points
une méthodologie claire une équipe avec
ces énergies capables de développer un
projet
et la rigueur pour aller au bout de ses
rêves
et si aujourd'hui je dois finir avec une
seule phrase
soyez ivre
et donnez-vous l'ambition de votre
ivresse merci beaucoup